to be uh you never want to be sacked
that many times you know 400 times up
basically is
is way too many 400 too many um you know
so i think that's a big
the big thing that we got to fix that's
got to be fixed we got to get better up
front
that it's not just passing i think you
know in terms of everything you do you
know you
it controls the game with the comments
you made about the offensive line and
being frustrated with getting hit did
you mean that as sort of a direct
criticism of
the offensive line in general not not at
all about the offensive line i think
that
i also mentioned you know i mentioned
that you know the reality is
that i can do better too you know i
think that's we're all we're all trying
to find ways to win
all trying to find ways to be better
russell wilson an eventful offseason for
him
he comes in at number five on the chris
sims top 40 quarterback countdown
downs two spots yeah from number
three he's number two he started last
year last year he was number two
yeah yeah i made him three when we did
that week 10 kind of
uh you know re-rank last year but yes
you know uh it's still phenomenal we
know that
still one of the best quarterbacks in
the game i mean
captain clutch as far as all that
stuff's concerned
awesome deep ball thrower everything
like that yeah we had some other guys
that
are really good quarterbacks too who
jumped them and we're going to talk
about them in a few minutes but
man russell wilson you know still big
time player
big time playmaker you know can of
course extend plays
he's not quite the runner he used to be
or the extender of plays that he used to
be
but it's still really high level stuff
and he
is without a doubt still one of the best
quarterbacks in this in this game
hang on why do you think he can't run
like he used to it's not like he's
40. no well no i know but it's not it's
not the same
russell wilson from three
four five years ago now he still can run
but i don't feel like his
i feel like other people have passed him
up for maybe being better runners
and scramblers than he had and then he
is i guess is what i'm saying
you know yeah there's a few out there
it's still really good don't get me
wrong i just don't feel like he's quite
as explosive as he was
uh that's why you make a good point you
make a good point like
yeah hey hey russell wilson's really
fast then here comes kyler murray and
you forget about russell wilson being
fast because kyler murray's faster
yeah that yeah it's not like yeah
exactly i'm not trying to make an
indictment on russell wisdom but i'm
going like yeah he's not as fast as he
once was there's kyla murray there's
lamar jackson
there's desean watson there's josh allen
they're both
to me those guys are better runners than
him now so they've kind of passed him up
in that that department
so that that's how i would look at it
but man i mean russell wilson we know
there's been limitations in that offense
it's not always quarterback
friendly uh it's not always easy to play
quarterback there in seattle with a
defensive head coach and all those type
of things
he makes a number of big time throws but
last year i will say
that there were moments where you know
first time i ever saw him get a little
reckless you know with the football or
maybe impatient to a degree
and the one thing that i'll say negative
too that still just
i've always said this but it still jumps
out to me is
there are completions left on the field
at times
he he can be greedy and look for more
mike he might have a
six yard eight yard out by the tight end
right he'll look at it he's open
and he'll kind of just [ __ ] the ball and
pump it and go now i don't want to throw
and he'll dance around and do something
and you go well man he was open
and wait that guy was open and he'll
look for something better and
you know hey he does find things better
sometimes but at times it can stall
their offense out too to where you go
well no now you had to throw the ball
away or you got sacked because you held
on to the ball longer than you should
have
and those are little things about his
game that um
i think bothered me a little last year
for sure
it was obvious that he was unhappy in
seattle it was obvious that he wanted
out i don't care what he says now
yeah between him and his agent back in
february and march it was clear
that he was looking for a new place to
go he wasn't happy with the way things
had gone in seattle
he wasn't happy with the fact that he
only has one super bowl win
in his nine nfl seasons i saw that espn
reported and
bleacher report amplified russell wilson
is happy and all in
after seattle's offseason my reaction to
that is he's only all in because he
couldn't get all
out yeah and that still lingers and and
i raise that now because it traces to
the desire by russell wilson to be
patrick mahomes to be the guy through
whom the offense runs
fair question chris is russell wilson
good enough to be that guy
he is good enough to be that guy i don't
think he can i don't think he can do it
to the level of mahomes or josh allen
who we have not revealed on this ranking
in this list yet either um i i don't no
not at this point of his career
but i still think that yes he could
still be
in that type of offense and deliver
high-end results
and a lot of big time football plays
there's no doubt about it
uh so yeah does he have a point in maybe
wanting the offense to be a little bit
more
russell wilson centric sure he does i
mean he's looking at it like those guys
and he wants to play that free-flowing
awesome quarterback game and
i don't have to worry about managing
anything i can just drop back and throw
the ball
all the time i get it but yeah he's up
there in seattle they play a different
way and i don't see pete carroll ever
really budging on on that that aspect
i you know i i think one of the
practical realities here
and and this gets back to what we were
talking about with relative speed it's
not that he's gotten slower
it's that faster quarterbacks are now in
the league i'll broaden that
and say it's not that russ has
diminished it all right
but you know five years ago yeah
aaron rodgers russell wilson tom brady
now you got patrick mahomes josh allen
lamar jackson kyler murray
we have better quarterbacks quarterbacks
who are
better as young quarterbacks than
russell wilson was and will be better in
their primes than russell wilson was so
it's
nothing about him has fundamentally
changed it's that
the younger guys are just better than
they've ever been
so if you're one of the guys who's
already been there they're gonna jump
you
and that's just the way it is and that
may have something to do with the fact
that he's at number five
it is it really is you know we talk
about it a lot right i mean
there's a lot of freaky good
quarterbacks in the nfl right now
we don't have a quarterback problem in
this league we don't
as i've always said and you've heard me
say we have an offensive coordinator
problem in my opinion
not a quarterback problem you know i i
think a lot of quarterbacks would be
look
looked at a lot differently if we had
you know some better coordinators behind
them he would go whoa he is pretty good
no he's always been good
he's just been in some you know crappy
situations uh and and russell wilson
certainly has not had the benefit of
like
the greatest offenses in the world
there's no doubt about that
he's still dangerous he's still arguably
the clutches quarterback in the game
i mean when russell wilson has the ball
late in the fourth quarter and they're
down
i mean it's almost shocking and
mind-blowing if they don't score and win
the game
i mean they they they put a lot on them
from that way
i've never seen a team you know to give
him more credit here
that is more comfortable being down by
10 points with nine minutes left in the
fourth quarter and just being like
we just want to give the ball to russell
with two minutes with a chance to win
i mean it seems like they play that way
at times and of course
hey i don't want to take take also into
we got to take into account too
you know he did some really good things
and especially early this year
when their defense was on pace to be the
worst defense in the history of football
i mean he did do uh made some incredible
plays was playing at a really high level
uh so we're still like that's why i
don't want this to be a demeaning thing
on russell wilson i'm glad you're kind
of saying
what i wanted to say there's just some
really other good quarterbacks that i
think have
just surpassed him a little bit here in
the last year
yeah i mean i really do think that that
is the bottom line
that that he's still who he was there
are just other guys who
have come to the league who are doing
things better and that leads to number
four
on the list who wears number four for
the houston texans
for now will likely never play for the
texans again and remember this is just a
football assessment this has nothing to
do with the off-field issues
of deshaun watson but chris as you have
said for the past few years
deshawn watson so freaking awesome he is
comes in at number four on the list now
how did you ultimately draw the line
between because i have a feeling it came
down to wilson or watson for four
what gave watson the bump over wilson i
think
you know i think the big thing is i
think watson is more talented at this
point of his career than russell wilson
i think his arm's stronger i think he's
a better athlete and honestly
you know he's a little bit more
consistent in his decision making and
throwing in the football than russell
wilson it's not by a lot but a little
bit
you know deshawn watson is the greatest
he's he's great for me and all my
arguments to go
like nobody argues that desean watson
isn't a top five quarterback in football
there you go you got a franchise
quarterback he's the man well when you
have crap around him you still can go
four and 12
even with the man at quarterback and he
had crap around him
i mean again four and 12 they could have
been
easily seven and nine if the rest of the
team didn't crap and pee down their leg
at times
i mean they had a chance well you know
think about you know again
four and 12 and we're gonna put that on
his gravestone that he was four and
twelve between
what was a bad snap in the colts game
when they're on what the two yard line
to win the football game
you know kiki kuti kutay fumbles on the
two yard line a few weeks later against
the colts
they could have beat the titans i mean
there was so many close games where you
go
they're only in this game for one reason
they have a crappy defense no run game
and they were in it because of number
four
that's all there is to be said we're not
talking about off the field like you
said
on the field the guy's a superstar he's
tough as hell
he wants to beat you from the pocket he
stays in the pocket as long as possible
and has a great feel of like okay now
it's time to get out and make something
happen
and uh excuse me as i'm choking on
myself but he uh
he's a really special football player
and they just need to support him a
little bit more and help him out
after they traded deandre hopkins you
saw a silver lining there
in so far as it removed a crutch
for deshaun watts yes that he wouldn't
feel compelled to stare down deandre
hopkins throw it to deandre hopkins
kind of like a corollary to the obj
thing where you just throw to the open
guy
you don't worry about who it is did you
see growth in watson last year by
not having hopkins there because he had
his best year ever that
he didn't have deandre hopkins yeah
that's it i mean he had his best year
ever
that that's it now did it make their
team better that deandre hopkins was
there
absolutely not they needed a guy that
could make some crazy plays like we saw
him make
in arizona that maybe they would have
won a game or two that they didn't
if he was on the field but i do think
overall
yes the play from watson was better
you know it was a little bit of a crutch
you know when in doubt wait i don't know
what i'm looking at i'll just always
throw it to deandre hopkins
oh this i shouldn't throw to him here in
this coverage but i'm gonna
because he's deandre hopkins listen i
know there's some of that that goes on
but yeah now he used more of the system
more of the weapons you know that were
available
and it became a little bit less of a i
don't know where he's going to go with
the football he played phenomenal
he really did and you know i just can't
say enough about the guy on the field
and what he did he just they got a
they got to have a defense they need a
little bit of a running game they need a
you know legit number one receiver to be
alongside
but he's not going to be there he's not
going to not anymore i'm just saying
i know i'm just saying that's what they
need if everybody wants to see what the
guy can really be and how special he is
we're going to find out what he can
really be with another team whether it's
the eagles the dolphins the broncos or
someone else whether it's this year or
next year
we're going to find out and that's
another mystery that will be solved to a
certain extent
while we are on hiatus although we'll be
tracking this yeah
carefully at profootballtalk.com will he
show up for training camp will he be
placed on the commissioner exempt list
will they decide
beforehand which i think they should
whether or not he'll be on paid leave
and let him know let the texans know let
other teams know
so people can make decisions good
decisions smart decisions about
the future here's one thing though where
i think desean watson can be
even better and i'm going to couch this
as a potential
positive not as a negative but i talk to
someone very knowledgeable
about russell wilson and deshawn watson
not that long ago yeah
wilson falls into the category of the
tom brady
peyton manning drew brees live
breathe eat sleep poop
football pardon me yeah but it's an a
never-ending obsession
and it's work work work work work work
work
deshawn watson's not there yet he could
get there
right but he's not there yet he doesn't
put in the work away from the facility
and he doesn't necessarily show up early
and stay late
not quite to the degree remember there
was the narrative about ben
rothersberger at one point
and and i guess to a certain extent you
could say it's still there
but but will watson grow into
the guy who is consumed
all the time with football doing
everything he can to get the absolute
most out of his skills and can he
squeeze out
more if he does that that's the real
question i have
because i think he could be even better
than four because
he's where he is without the
all-consuming
obsession that a russell wilson or a tom
brady would have
if watson develops that yeah does he
threaten patrick mahomes well he's the
best quarterback
he's got that type of talent i mean he's
got top you know one two
three type talent in the league there's
no doubt he does you're right
it's the next the next step i mean you
know and i don't want to
portray this this is a guy that's still
i think a student of the game and works
hard and does those things but you're
you're right
like there's a next level and sometimes
you don't really know
where that next level is unless you've
been around a guy that's been around one
of those guys you mentioned
or you know yeah there's there's
somebody's got to show you the way to a
degree
so i'm sure but we've seen aspects of
what was that game last year that they
lost and he stayed on the field
remember like after the game it was an
hour and a half after the game he was
out there with his quarterback coach
going through reads and things like that
so i do think we're seeing maturity but
yeah he's probably been
you know again guys like breeze and
brady they have to be like that
to a degree you know there was no other
choice they needed to take advantage of
all that
sometimes the watson's mahomes and the
allens of the worlds they
they you know again they've been able to
kick kick ass
sorry london you know just with their
great physical ability their whole life
so they're not always like i gotta get
in there at 5 45 and
understand the square root of 64. and
understand this blitz and that blitz i
know every you know
that's where yes that's where the
seasoning professionalism comes into
town but mike the one thing i don't want
to lose here is
the guy's awesome he leaves really when
i broke it down between him and russell
wilson
you know he just i think he's a more
consistent thrower
he leaves less yards on the field than
russell wilson throwing the football
you know there was a few games even when
i went back to watch the you know wilson
a few weeks ago where i went
man there's some plays here where it's
dk metcalf one on one you can't let the
defense get away with this
you can't you gotta throw it to dk he's
one on one against some schlep
corner and you gotta do it this is gonna
help you out the team out and all that
watson doesn't make those mistakes oh
it's brandon cooks on an average quarter
zoo laser beam oh there's nobody open
you know he has an aggressive down the
field throwing system
he does not get a lot of dink and dunk
completions and
he is a pretty damn good decision maker
to go along i mean look at this
8.9 yards per attempt 70 completion
percentage 4 800 yards
no running game you knew they were gonna
drop back and throw the ball
every game all game he was their only
hope
and uh that's why i you know again gotta
praise the guy for what he does on the
field because he's very special
and they had an interim coach for 12
games two exactly o'brien for four games
right i'm still perplexed that you think
the answer to the question of what is
the square root of 64 is difficult
no well you're right i should have said
a higher one you're right but you know
what
you know what i meant do you know what
the square root of 64 is it's eight
thank you very much i was pretty good at
math but yes
wow you know you're you're work and
there's probably
percy behind you telling you to actually
we were really good in math
i was okay yes i was that was pretty
good
but uh uh yes what but but that's
you know it it's the same thing to where
you know i don't like always that with
like yeah breeze brady all that
you know i i get that but these are
young guys who are finding their ways
and they are molded a little differently
and he will learn to be that machine
you know mentally like you're talking
about and understand how to put that
little extra work in to
maybe get them the team and him over the
top
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports